through the city like I'm on to get it
through
the and now
Brandon
six hey Monday morning welcome October
23rd kids almost time for Halloween
almost time for Halloween it is upon us
I got the pumpkins out went to the
pumpkin patch yesterday that thing was
way too busy I regret going on a Sunday
but nonetheless we got the pumpkins done
it's the third pumpkin patch of the Year
already we got one more to go we got one
more freaking pumpkin patch to go kids
love them kids love them posted a
picture on my Instagram story not the
wall chin this goat was dead they said
it was sleeping but I didn't see much
movement and when we we're were there
for about an hour and then when I was
leaving he still was sleeping quote
unquote uh so I just told my kid yeah
he's taking a long hard nap son there he
is oh there
yeah I said but I'm told this goat is
sleeping definitely not
dead that goat was dead not but
apparently that's what they do when it
gets hot out they like the
snooze I don't trust goats man they give
off a evil Vibe they give off a evil
Vibe uh straight off the the jetway from
Austin Texas where I was doing a little
show called fight campaign with Mr Joe
Rogan Eddie Bravo and Brian Ken for the
big UFC pay-per-view UFC
294 in my head almost but # UFC 294
that's cool
um yeah man flew in on Friday out
directly after the fight that that has
to be the fastest main card of all time
is the fastest of all time I think it
was 24 minutes
long I'm I'm serious 2 24 well look at
it 3 5 3 2 1 so that's let's just do
easy map there that's 3 6 11 in fight
time that's 14 minutes they add in the
walkouts they tried to put in some
fillers them boys had to do work anic DC
and the boys uh had to do some work
filling that time cuz it was everything
was so fast then you had the the Ania
Johnny Walker um that one probably took
the most time just because there's all
the chaos but let's get right into the
fight
card oh boy um interesting card right a
lot of things happen that we would not
have assumed that's what makes a sport
great
um we'll kick it off with Hamza and
kamaro I want to dive in most on that in
the main event and then we'll get to
Johnny Walker and maged but with uh
Hamza and
Camaro there's two ways to look at this
depending what kind of fight fan you are
is it that hamza's
overhyped or is it that Camaro's
definitely not washed up and he's pretty
damnn good so I think you can your
takeaways can there can be both I think
think maybe hamzad is a little overhyped
and this come from a guy who's probably
responsible for a tad bit of that hype I
absolutely think hot's the next big star
but I think we need to pump the brakes
just to Tad when you look at his resume
compared to other guys especially Dana
said he is going to get the middleweight
title shot next we'll get to that but
when you look at his kind of resume and
especially his last few fights that got
him to this title shot shot probably not
um the
most accomplished resume in order to get
a title shot you know there's definitely
guys who have been pushed faster that uh
didn't deserve it but when you look at
Hamot I think the hype kind of outshines
the actual work he's doing inside that
octagon um and listen I'm I'm one of
them I've been saying from the from the
chesa rooftop that this guy is your next
Champion but that being said after the
fight on Saturday I went let's slow down
Brendan let's just slow it down a sec
because he beat camar Usman in a
majority decision you could give Usman
one of those rounds but still he fought
a you know a welterweight and this he's
going to be competing for a middleweight
title shot there so he beat a
welterweight okay then he fought Kevin
Hollen okay still that was at a catch
weight that's still not top middle
weight okay but then before that he beat
a legit Contender at middleweight right
no he beat Gilbert Burns and it was a
decision and it was a fight of the night
and that thing was damn close he gave
him all he can
handle okay man okay but then before
that he beat an actual Big Time
middleweight
Contender no no no he beat uh leech um
yeah and then for that be Gerald merart
so Mer's the big win there in the
middleweight division yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's fighting for a title like what
you know so I just
think the the hype has kind of taken
over and we've turned him into this chch
and Boogeyman which he is but he's also
human and again I'm the biggest hamzat
fan I think you'll be a champion at 70 I
think you be a champion at 85 and depend
how he does that 85 those bigger boys I
think he could eventually as he matures
could go to 205 I know it's a big ass
there but I I think he could have some
success there but I I we got to pump the
brakes just to Tad and that being
said if he does get the title shot which
it sounds like he's going to which dupes
is like what the hell is going on here
we get to why do police should have the
next shot but it when Dana says
something I think that's what's going to
happen especially dup's turning down the
title shot against Izzy that's going
against him so hamza's probably the next
in line to fight Strickland for the
middleweight
title as of today on October
23rd and going just based off straight
up the data that we have the video
footage of fight footage that we have of
homot and going based off the fight foot
we have of Strickland I would put all my
money on Strickland to beat Hamot in
five rounds cuz if if you look at Hamot
right
now you know he's he's not there's
there's nothing in his
past five fights that would lead you
to assume he's going to be able to
steamroll Strickland that first round
maybe this beginning of the second round
could be a bit of a challenge for
Strickland but if you don't get that
done in that first round or round and
half stricken is the worst match for
Hamot now you look at his cardio you
look at who uh Strickland has beat
before the way he's beat him the way he
melts dudes down I think his grappling
is underrated and just the tenacity and
then going based off the hamzo versus
Usman fight you know Hamza blew his gas
tank in that first round now the cab out
there well he broke his hand okay let's
say that that still don't have to do
much with cardio so that first round 108
108 all day that second round Usman some
think he won it some of the judges gave
it to him he's hanging around he's
having success on the feet that third
round again more success on the feet
than gets taken down and obviously lost
the third round but still if that's
Strickland this dude gets better as the
fight goes on and once he has success
he's come that that that Strickland that
white boy Title Wave that this dude
brings that Philly shell it is a issue
for Hamza man so I think the odds are
out already and they have hamz out as a
pretty sizable favor boy I would put a
significant amount of money on
Strickland in that fight again
stylistically it is uh oh so now see
remember we looked at this last week
Hamot was a massive favorite I think he
was minus 400 minus three something now
he's a minus 135 jump on it now that's
that Line's going to change that Line's
going to change Strickland from going
based off the the fight footage that
we've seen you look at the way he's
there goes so he was minus 300 plus 250
that's and that's
uh yeah how long ago was that though T
that's from that's October 21st so that
was the night of the fight and look how
that Line's already switching I mean
there's just there's
nothing from hot's past in that octagon
there's no evidence there that would go
yeah he he's going to steamroll
Strickland nothing there you look at the
way Strickland's dismantled guys the way
he applies the pressure he melts dudes
if if Hamza doesn't get done in that
first round it is a nightmare form him
Strickland that second especially the
third fourth and fifth I mean if if this
was a five round fight you can't tell me
hamzat wins that fight against
Usman the way it was looking and the
success he was having on the feet you're
like I don't know dude I don't know that
first round like this is a nightmare
this thing's over but is a second round
you know who having some success
shutting down the takedowns you know
Newman's I mean obviously a tiny
middleweight Strickland's no punk man
he's beat big boys he's melted some of
those dudes over there in dagistan over
there in Russia over there in chesna he
melts those dudes so again there's
nothing there's no evidence that's going
to show you that hamat should beat
Strickland besides your own bias that's
me I'm biased as hell but I'm able to
put this to the side and go oo that's
not an easy fight for Hamza at
all there and there's also and one of
the reasons we're saying this
is were I don't know who else is saying
this but one of the reasons
is in what world do we think Hamza
deserves a title
shot if if you look at dup dup is like
what are you kidding me look at dup's
last five let's go through hamza's last
five let's go through dupes now I'm not
going bad on hamzat this is very black
and white this take my bias out of it
I'm a huge hamzat fan but if you're just
looking at if this is the NFL this is
the NBA you're just looking at
resumés so this is dupy's last let's go
four this last four so uh first of all
he's undefeated in the UFC but we'll
take out the first two um but the first
two were koos so that's cool and they
fights Brad Tavarez tough night in the
office he beats some pretty decisively
unanimous decision okay then he fights
Darren till Darren Till's no walk in the
park that's a that's a bit of a that's a
fight there he submits him with a face
crank and that's fight of the night then
he fights Derek Brunson who's been a
perennial top 10 guy always a tough
problem to solve he tko's him tko's in
the second round okay in the the corner
stoppage and then they give him Robert
Whitaker who is the toughest man in the
division not named Izzy
couldn't be a worse matchup for dupes
and he starches him in the second round
savagely tko's
him and then they offer him the fight
against Izzy and for whatever reason
shoulder I don't know he turns it down
and now they're like nope here's
Hamot and I would love if you're Hamot
to maner I'd love to hear the
argument hamzad deserving tashad over
dupes I would I what's the best argu
ument
go uh but he beat Kamar hman he wasn't
impressive he beat a guy a welterweight
on a 10day notice yeah but he broke his
hand okay well why couldn't he finish
him in the first
round uh he beat Kevin Holland that was
on like a three- hour notice Kevin
Holland was supposed to fight somebody
else dude supposed to fight just an
elite Striker and Rodriguez and you
switched it with three hours before and
and I guess he submitted him it's still
not even
a
middleweight but he beat Gilbert Burns
that was back and forth
dude that was back that was back and
forth and that guy's also a welterweight
for God's sakes okay but his best wins
over
leech okay and remember he fought really
quick back to back to back to back when
they were over there during the
lockdowns
okay how is that more impressive than
what D polies have been doing I don't
get it
I get the hype I get the the you know
they signed a deal with Saudi Arabia and
there's all that the other thing that's
working against Hamot is the rumor is
because of for whatever reason this dude
can't
travel to the
states okay so again if you're hot's
management and you're mean with Dana
right now like yep you said hamzat next
right yep yeah we want to do in Vegas we
want to do in Vegas
in
March right uh hamach can't go to Vegas
excuse me he can't because of Visa
issues for whatever is going on there we
have to do it back in Abu Dhabi or we
got to do in Saudi Arabia you guys have
one in March right it's supposed to be a
big fight night you could do Strickland
and Hamot in Saudi Arabia on that big
fight night we'd love that right but
Strickland's the champ and has beat a
lot of
middleweights and just beat Izzy
decisively and he has to come to you cuz
you have Visa issues
yep youcon go okay is that not crazy
that isn't that
nuts and Strickland was on a podcast
with Don fry and he's like I'll fight
him doesn't deserve it by no means does
he deserve it after that
performance I'll fight him for five
rounds but I would ask Strickland okay
will you go to the Middle East and do it
though and if I'm the chamam absolutely
not then he's not getting the title shot
if Hamza can only fight in Saudi Arabia
or in the Middle East or
Dubai okay then you can't be champed
dude you can't dim the rules because the
champ is from California the champ just
beat Izzy in his own backyard arguably
the greatest mwe of all time n you beat
him he beat the breakes off of him and
now you have a few WIS over
welterweights you probably shouldn't be
in a title picture and not only should
you not have this title shot but now the
actual champion Sean Strickland has to
come to your backyard what world are we
living in what are we
doing doesn't make
sense and dupes shot himself in the foot
because he turned down the fight with
Izzy so Dana has to discipline him but
that's not
right it's also not right to give a guy
who has two wins over inflated
middleweights it doesn't make any sense
none of it makes sense and this is
coming from a guy who a huge hom up fan
massive hom up fan I think he's the
future of the UFC that being said I
don't think he beat Strickland anytime
soon after from what we've seen I don't
think he beat Strickland I don't see it
I don't see it and for Camaro Usman you
you got to take your hat off to him
10day notice middleweight division
fighting the Chim Boogie man and you you
put he put on a show man one judge have
it 2828 I don't agree with that uh 2927
is fair the 108 in the first round sure
but for Camaro y everyone's saying he's
washed up only has one fight left his
knees are bad what you're doing is
you're discrediting how good Leon
Edwards is so if Camaro Usman this is
exactly what he should do he has he he
needs to chill wait you know whatever
injuries he has chill wait he's been so
active so just chill
you got to hope that Kobe comington
beats Leon Edwards because if Leon
Edwards beats Kobe comington forget
about welterweight you're never going
back to welterweight you're not going to
beat Leon Edwards that's your Achilles
heel it's never happening we've seen it
twice not happening okay cool now if
Kobe Covington beats Leon Edwards we go
in Sizzler because you have two wins
over him now you can go back to welto go
hold up you don't have to fight a
contender nothing y hey had a good
performance over here last time I was in
division I lost to the Camp he just lost
your Champion I have two wins over now
you don't have to wait you get a
straight boom straight elevator to the
title shot and Kobe comington so no one
should be a bigger Kobe comton fan than
Kamar Usman right now you have if you
want to go back to welterweight which
you should you need Kobe comton to beat
Leon Edwards otherwise there's nothing
for you
there so if you're tomorrow you're
sitting down you're like all right well
let's say Kobe loses I gu you stay at
middleweight I gu guess I'd be again
hamza's not there's some big boys at at
middleweight dupes is massive uh polasa
massive vtori massive those guys are big
big boys so even though he had a good
showing against Kamar Usman I'm sorry
Kamar Usman had a good shown against
Hamot hamza's not the biggest
middleweight so I'd be interested to see
how he handles a guy like paoc Costa
who's the massive dude how how he deals
with those B jar kir Mass massive so I
don't know if he has a future at
middleweight but he's going to have no
choice if Leon Edwards beats Kobe
kington so Usman should be Kobe kon's
biggest fan right now biggest
fan it's interesting though I don't see
how in what world they give hamz out a
title shot even though they told him
he's going to get it it doesn't make any
sense in any facet we got to pump the
breaks down a little bit and that's all
good he's going to get there it's just
not there right now not there right now
he's not beating Strickland right now
not
happening nightmare for
him uh then the main event you had Mev
versus Alexander volovski
in hindsight I think people are going oh
banovski took the risk didn't work out I
bet he regrets it because now as soon as
I fight in as soon as he got knocked out
with a head kick I went well that we're
never seeing that again that was the
risk for all you right now who are you
know Sunday quarterbacks Monday morning
experts going Alexander should have
never done that man yeah that's why
you're not one of the greatest to ever
do it Alexander volkanovski takes these
risk in order to be Alexander
volkanovski of course you wouldn't do it
of course you're sitting in your studio
on Monday going oh he took the man this
wasn't enough he messed up we lost that
I know but to achieve greatness you got
to take some shots okay so he shot for
the moon land on the Stars he's still a
world champion he's still fighting
toia he's still fighting Ilia toia he's
out I think they G him a 60-day
suspension he can still fight in January
should he is the question should he jump
back in the camp shortly here after
getting koed like that with a head kick
probably not should he learn from Izzy
who's been so active and he caught up
with him and he had suffered these
losses I think a big part of his demise
with these losses is he was too active
and just got worn out
so you think that camp his his head
coach Eugene would go take a take a page
out of uh Izzy's book he should have
chilled a little more but then volovski
comes out in the press conference goes
when I don't have a camp going
on what' he say he gets
depressed he says he needs something
like that that kind of structure
otherwise he goes to like a different
place like yeah he needs stuff like that
I don't know if he said he's depressed
but it's a mental thing for sure like he
needs to chase that dragon and this is
the like who knows if he's drinking and
doing that stuff when he's you know not
training for someone I don't know he was
very like kind of like very like short
with it yeah I he's emotional too so I
don't know what's going on there you
know and he he has a wife and kids you
know especially he say he has a happy
family everything it's just he needs
that the Beast Dad yeah he just he needs
that motivation to do yeah and the the
level of like discipline and when you're
chasing that and you have this goal this
that you want to accomplish I I I I get
that and this is the problem so many
fighs
have and and we love volkanovski be
because he's so authentic and it's so
honest but that same ambition that same
Drive remember that never really leaves
a lot of guys especially at his level
the issue is is when you're 0 and three
he's not he's going to dominate for a
long time but the issue is is when
you're at the tail end of your career
how many of us sit down and go God can
you believe Tony Ferguson's still doing
it can you believe BJ Pen's still doing
it can you believe insert old Legend who
keeps doing it why does he just leave
this is why all of them are like that
all of them like I don't get it why
can't these guys just move on because
they're wired like this unless I was
fortunate enough to take all this energy
and all this crazy energy and discipline
and ambition I have and channel
something else thank God but some of
these guys don't so when you question go
I can't believe this guy's still
fighting what else you want him to do
man what else you want him to do
it's no different you know obviously
it's different because you're talking
about you know life and death but those
special forces guys T those tip of the
spare guys when they have this special
set of skills and they get done and
they're with their boys and they're you
know they have these Ambitions and their
their these crazy crazy missions like
that those high stakes and fighting
those high stakes when that all that
leaves you're just like okay what am I
what am I supposed to do I'm supposed to
go sit sit at a desk and push insert
whatever product and have a boss what
those guys aren't wired for that they're
just not they're not people like I don't
get it man what don't you get yeah CU
you have never had those same
aspirations those guys they can't fit in
with everybody else they can't they're
wired different so for Volcan I get it
but he's also pretty active it's not
like he's taking a year off or there's
not contend ERS now at his Division if
he beats Ilia there's not much that this
words can get dicey there's not a lot
going on for
him he's the greatest featherweight to
ever do it so once he beats Ilia which
again is not the easiest fight that's
why I
don't agree with fighting in January
after getting head kick ko'ed that's the
problem yeah no no just do it in March I
know it's that's still a quick
turnaround just chill dude M we got to
figure out how to occupy your mind and
your body so you're not just fighting
nonstop dude that can't be the way to do
it can't take a page from your boy Izzy
talk to Izzy about it I'm sure he does
his head coach Eugene should be like
dude we got to slow all you boys are
crazy not only they crazy but they're
the best in the world you got slow
down so for him obviously Ilia is next
and I don't think should be in January
but I'm sure he's going to do in January
that's not the easiest fight by any
means but he he's the best feather
featherweight to ever do it he should be
a big favorite for a reason so kudos to
him after that I don't know what they're
going to do um for
Islam his two
choices are gatei or Charles Olivera
that's his two choices nothing knocked
your hair back no one's foaming at the
wiener to watch those fights and that's
not a knock on gatei I'll watch gatei
take my money first team all violence
BMF belt he take my money when he fights
take my
money but unfortunately for MF he's been
so dominant you're not like oh I have to
see what's next fanovi was this
interesting thing right and that first
fight was so close I'm all about that
Charles Ola I'm like okay he's going to
mollywop him gatei I'm like well he's
had two title shots before saw against
khabib probably goes down the similar
way if I'm Dana if I'm the UFC brass I
give it to
gaii even though Charles L has a win
over him what he did do Dustin poier
winning by head kick
KO M just won by head kick
KO maybe he can land something he can
get in that phone booth you know [__]
fight heavy on the
[__] so I I guess gatei that that that'
be my preference there if it's Charles
ol okay but I don't think either one
beats him at all what about what he said
he's like he wants to go up and fight
the winner of Colby and Leon he doesn't
have enough title defenses at
lightweight in order to demand a shot at
welterweight has defend that belt he
should beat gatei then beat Charles L if
that's what they want to do and and do
that now G gamr was the the next in line
he was there he was the backup
fighter
again I would if you're gam rat's team
and I'm a huge fan of gamrat
savage but if you're game's team Okay
click on him J go over go over his
record gamr yeah gameat tell me why he
deserved a title shot let's go over his
last fights in what world do you think
this and he is so damn good but don't
forget he lost to daru not too long ago
his two wins Jaylen Turner was a split
decision and then FIV with the with the
knee
injury
yeah and he's he specializes in heavy
grappling marev versus gamrat I love
grappling so I'm into it but if you're
the UFC tough fight to sell yeah as far
as selling yeah for sure also his his
resume yeah he's won two out his last
three before that his toughest fight he
lost to
darush
okay it's a tough sale
man so for mchv he needs to defend the
belt I would say at least two more times
and really Dominate and then we can go
up to you got to clean out the division
and then he can go up like Izzy did you
have to do rematches in order to to get
to 205 and it was a huge ask against Yan
so for Islam he's not there yet where he
can demand a 170 fight I would love it
but it makes no sense we have we got to
have some structure it can't be all this
WWE Madness this guy this guy jump in
weight classes we don't want that he
needs to dominate that Division and then
jump up and Leon Edwards needs to beat
Kobe comton which is a big big
if yeah I would say if l Edwards takes
out Colby and then takes out
Muhammad then Islam and Islam takes out
Charles takes out gatei then you do it
we're a year away those two fights could
happen for each guy in a year 2025 we
can talk about this right now no way not
happening not
happening because there's still a guy in
uh shovot you remember is a bit of a
monster there at welterweight be to see
what he does
um you got Ian Machado Gary there you
got JDM there you got some fun upand
comers Sean Brady even though he had the
hiccup against uh Bal you got some you
got some fun stuff at welterweight
lightweight a little different animal
not a whole lot going on
there not a whole lot at
all so yeah um and then the real shame
was the magedov the anv the the an yeah
magedov ankl Johnny Walker fight now it
was labeled a no contest which does no
contest of legal knee shouldn't a legal
knee be a DQ where I come from yes yeah
because that fight would have gone on if
there wasn't a legal knee thrown no no
matter if it was intentional or not you
still threw an illegal knee that should
be a DQ that should be a win for Johnny
Walker why was the fight compromised
because maged and KV decided to throw an
illegal knee while to down opponent a no
contest means no one won no one lost it
doesn't move the division in any
direction neither guy can move on we got
to do it
again if they were more strict on ey
pokes uh groin strikes fence
grabs illegal knees if there was
Zero kind
of zero tolerance where if you throw uh
an eye poke if you hit somebody in the
nuts if you throw an illegal knee if you
do the fence grab or grab a point no
matter what and if the fight can't go on
because of an eye poke a groin strike or
legal knee it's a de you lose the fight
you're going to get way less of this
right now these guys are getting away
with this because what do we do you poke
somebody in the eye they go uh don't do
that again the guy has one [__] eye
now dude you kick him in the nuts you
give him five minutes and come back out
now if you take a point I guarantee you
we see less of this but we're so Loosey
Goosey with it and that the other the
the fighters compromised and now this
fighter Johnny Walker this had title
implications because you
have the title fight in November with
Pier with Alex Pier you have that fight
going
on this if Johnny Walker gets a home run
walk-off flying knee he's probably going
to get catapulted up to a title shot now
we got to redo this cuz you dumb asses
labeled a no
contest and that
doctor asked Johnny Walker where you at
he said the desert I'll take that dude
that's pretty solid were you expecting
the exact [__] location like it's
Google Maps dumbass
that's pretty solid for a guy who
doesn't speak English you have a middle
eastern doctor asking a guy who's fluent
in Portuguese his second language is
English Second Language being very
generous here and go where are you the
desert okay it works for me dumbass and
now we get a no
contest so they're just going to rebook
it they're going to stack that November
December card that's what's going to
happen which okay I'll take it and Kia
this poor guy this poor his entire life
is just put on hold now part of it's his
fault the draw is not his fault the draw
against Yan's not his fault the illegal
knee is his fault the only reason why we
don't have a decisive Victory here or
Victor is because he decided to throw an
illegal knee that should be a
DQ no questions asked this is clear as
day you threw an illegal knee I didn't
mean to doesn't matter I poked him the
has one eye doesn't matter I hit him in
the nuts didn't mean to doesn't matter
but when they go oh it's just a warning
that's the issue these guys at this
Elite level know they can get away with
it because you allow it you
morons how this is uh no contest is
insane dude insane and Johnny Walker
should be upset they can't push the rth
and do all that stuff you you got lucky
cuz usually like oh that is frowned upon
usually get KCK only in the UFC dude
only in the
UFC only in the UFC can you push the ref
and act that way and no repercussions we
go I get it unless Dana doesn't like you
U remember well then you're banned for
life yeah yeah then you're banned for
life that guyy sitting on his couch
right now like what the hell you're not
Johnny Walker
sir yeah those I don't get I don't know
if it's a commission I think it's like a
commission thing because if you're not
able to continue from like a like a you
know you know illegal knee like Alain
right with Peter Yan pan if you can't
continue then usually you get the win so
I guess it just depends on the
commission I don't know how it is over
there and it's also how I think the
fight has to be Sur P time to that's
that's the biggest one but if even if
even it's a one one second three seconds
it should be nope you threw an illegal
knee you're out disqualified totally
with you on that all the points should
be taken away every single time
something happens yeah
makv looked
amazing called out Kai Cara France I
would like to see it he's a little
[__] Savage dude yeah CED nerov
looked
insane
mamedov the pirate over Bruno Silva fun
to watch as Dana said how can it be from
dagistan with no
wrestling I'm a fan though a redhead D
Sayan redhead I don't trust redheads but
you know he has a lot of anger being a
redhead that guy gives problems on the
feet he's only 29 suppos he has a
million fights has like 70 fights how do
you have zero wrestling that's what's
insane if you're from Russia yeah how do
you I mean what are we
doing what are we doing yeah I'm a fan
though we'll see what happens with him
it's all about matchups for him early on
yeah he has just a super cool look man
there's something cuz he has one eye
yeah it looks it looks badass though
that I've been telling Nick dve let me
take out your eye dude they look exactly
the same they look so much you want to
get a lot sexier you want to get some
chicks bro let me take out your eye look
at that dude and his nickname's the
pirate yeah which is awesome hell yeah
dude I'm a fan that's so Nick Davis
without a doubt it's Nick Davis yeah but
Nick has both eyes that's the problem
all right what do you got you uh all
right real quick ads we got some ads
dude got some ads all right let's take a
little break here and then we get back
to the fistic cuffs chat um cold turkey
may be great on sandwiches but there's a
better way to break your bad habits
we're not talking about some weird mind
voodo from some Instagram Guru from your
crazy neighbor no no no we're talking
about our sponsor we're talking about
fume and they look at the problem in a
different way not everything in a bad
habit is wrong so instead of a crazy
uncomfortable change where you get cold
sweats why not just remove the bad from
your habit that's right I'm talking
about fume instead of vapor fume uses
flavored
air so it's all the same stuff without
the bad stuff instead of electronics
fume is completely natural instead of
harmful chemicals fume likes to replace
that with delicious flavors you get it
instead of bad fume is good it's a habit
you're free to enjoy with no
repercussions making replacing your bad
habits super easy fume comes with an
adjustable airflow dial and Design
designed with movable parts and magnets
for fidgeting giving your fingers a lot
to do which is helpful for de-stress and
anxiety while you're breaking that bad
habit The Taste is fantastic they have
all sorts of delicious flavors so you're
not going to miss that old habit all
right uh stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but if it was
easy everyone would do it but switching
to fume is super easy it's enjoyable and
even fun fume has served over 150,000
customers has thousands of success
stories there's no reason that can't be
you join fume and accelerating
Humanity's breakup from destructible bad
habits by picking up the journey pack
today head to trif fume that's TR rfu
m.com use the code shab seab to save 10%
off when you get the journey pack today
trf nume.com use the code shab save an
additional 10% off your order today
fume oh yeah let's do it
Jen listen man when I started podcasting
an online store was the furthest thing
from my mind I was shelling out merch
myself selling it on my own website me
and my brother were packaging that thing
so if you got a shirt a fire and the kid
shirt for me back in the day that was
folded with these little fat fingers and
then I decided to step my game up with
Shopify it's so easy all right it's so
freaking easy Shopify is the global Comm
platform that helps you sell at every
stage of your business with your startup
you've been doing for a hot second
Shopify got you covered from the launch
your online shop stage to the first real
life store stage all the way to the did
we just hit a million order stage
Shopify is there to help you grow all
right Shopify helps you turn browsers
into buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout up to 36% better
compared to the other leading Commerce
platforms all right sell more with less
effort thanks to Shopify we got you
covered man Shopify Powers 10% of all
e-commerce in the US and shopify's
Global force behind all birds rothis
Brooklyn and millions of other
entrepreneurs of every size across 175
countries wow all right because business
that grow grow with Shopify sign up for
a $1 per month trial pair at shopify.com
Shob that's all lowercase Au all
lowercase go to shopify.com shopall
lowercase to grow your business no
matter what stage you're in shopify.com
shopall lowercase chaing
chaing Al
righty so Paula Costa was at the event
and he got attacked by some dude that
jumped the gate but not just any dude if
you're familiar with this Chetan Savage
he's also the same dude that pulled a
gun on a guy during a fight interview
this is a wild boy you know we don't wow
yeah if you know this guy he is a wild
boy but Kasa got a shot in at
least
bam and security was there like right
away Kasa dressed like a real estate
agent whoop your ass
though
yeah yeah if do your homework on this
jet in that threw that fist he's a wild
boy pulled a gun on a guy doing a fight
interview well didn't that's kind of
crazy look into
him all right this is another crazy
story so apparently three people during
the event that's that card they all had
staff infections and they HIIT it from
the commission this girl's staff
infection story is so like nasty I'll
just play it from here
it's this her translator translator is
like hold on one sec transl like what oh
it's disgusting appeared and I think now
it because everything is completely
blooded up um and so before I had to uh
make the way wait you know I I passed
out in the tub they brought me back to
to life I I I was back conscious
basically she had stuff on on her butt
and an absess was on her butt that
popped during the fight and it got all
bloody That's not healthy and it's like
so three people during that event had
staff so I saw a lot of comments saying
like damn if they're on the ground and
everything else the other Fighters that
come through you know they get scratched
and they have to touch the ground like
they staff's everywhere first of all
that staff's just to be clear for these
people like I can't believe they allow
him to fight now granted their cases are
in extreme condition staff's all over
that mat no matter what oh no matter
what every fight oh okay okay no matter
what yeah gotcha well I mean at least
staff's on every gym at it's the staff's
around at all times those Advanced
stages and how bad that is yeah it's
going to make it worse but saf is around
all the time didn't know that well I
know she had it hanging out of her anus
and it blew up it's nasty to hear that I
thought this was super cool uh Alex
volkanovski just just uh posted this
like I think yeah an hour two hours ago
he's way smaller yeah from Islam just
him and Islam I guess they're still
there hanging out and then uh he just
says all respect to Islam and his team
how can you not love volkanovski man
yeah actually they both had like a they
both said really cool things and yeah
yeah have have you heard a friend s this
to me with um hamzad so in English he
was like we all got to get along Let's
Stop The Killing but then what he said
in his native tongue
was completely different well he said
something like if he was allowed to he
would go to war right now with them yeah
my Muslim brothers and yeah it's a
little different yeah I mean it it's
kind of I never expected to see that
side of these guys so it's like it was
really cool to see that side of of his M
and Alex no no no no uh Hamza even Hamza
was in an interview with uh Caroline
Pierce and then he was just he couldn't
he couldn't keep talking he had to leave
because he was talking about the you
know the children so I was like I'm yeah
yeah yeah um I love both those guys both
class acts yeah
yeah uh this is pretty cool for that
bkfc 56 event Mike Perry versus Eddie
Alber there's a lot recognizable people
here dude my boy Todd Duffy Ben Rothwell
watch out for his right hand against the
cage take it from me Beck Rollins one of
our
favorites and then you know it falls off
after that but still you got Perry
versus The Underground King and Eddie
Alvarez and the other thing about you
know Mike Perry is a complete Savage
Eddie Alvarez stylistically he doesn't
lose these type of fights when it's a
foam Booth fight he doesn't lose those
look at his resume this by far Perry's
toughest fight now what Eddie did with
Chad Mendes different type of fight but
for for Eddie this is right up his alley
man I'm excited for this fight yeah
it'll be
fun the Todd Duffy uh Ben Rothwell cuz
beer knuckle jeez you know well yeah
you've you fought Ben but you know Todd
Duffy is his he's a train partner for a
long time freak complete freak freak
athlete dude and bear knuckle what but
be bear knuckle the there's listen
there's not a man walk in this planet as
tough as Ben rothell like bear knuckle
about toughness you know like is Luke
rockold a more skilled fighter than Mike
Perry absolutely and bear knuckle though
he broke his teeth it's not for
everybody
so is to is Todd Duffy a better
uh skilled fighter than Ben rothell 100%
but bear knuckle it's just a different
animal that's why Mike Perry's the face
of it is Mike Perry more skilled fighter
than Michael Venom page absolutely not
in Bear knuckle he absolutely is he's
just tough he's just tougher Ben rotho
is just tougher than all these guys it's
a special type of person to do bare
knuckle so we'll see but Todd Duffy with
bare knuckles good luck eating that
[__] right hand or left hand he can
do both he looks in great shape now too
the most recent pictures but he's always
been in great shape uh so there was this
thing that Nate Diaz posted not that
long ago you guys fell for it I didn't I
didn't I I just I just sented to the
group that was it but he said I mean it
looks dope here rematch it looks legit
breaking news rematch Paul versus Diaz
looks legit cuz they fought chin so he
just put Paul stas and then put a two on
December 15th looks legit to me though
yeah yeah because they fought before so
it's the same picture is when they fed
he just put a two on the end and you
think it's legit and they changed the
date December 15th live pretty easy uh
Jake Paul K said it's not happening so
this is from they both agreed to fight
MP most valuable promotions they said
that uh they won't be fighting and Nate
Diaz was offered a MMA fight in pfl
against Jake and Jake said yes but you
know nothing from Nate Nate's not going
to fight in pfl I know he's he talks so
much crap about
that all right uh Dylan danis is
officially free agent released from
Bellator and then I saw a post that says
uh right here this is from ma junkie
like this is Dylan saying I want UFC or
I'm going to retire yeah I don't know
well I he like let's make a lot of money
Dana like he actually tagged Dana in a
post so my first instinct and then d but
Dana let's make a lot of money at UFC at
Dana White right at Dana White yeah so
my first instinct was like there's no
way the UFC signs him right with a
striking can't have just Jitsu gu but
then if you go back
like the UFC's history they signed now
these guys are completely different as
far as credentials and one guy's
actually undefeated in mixed martial
arts because he's you know he is world
class when comes Jiu-Jitsu talking about
Dylan danis but if it's if the the goal
of the UFC is money they they they're
valid in some areas as far as fighting
obviously but they'll do these circus
acts don't get twisted they would sign
Logan Paul in a heartb they' sign Jake
Paul if they could those guys aren't
interested in the UFC right now right
and lo and Danny even said Never Say
Never when it came to
Logan but they did the CM Punk fight now
do you think that was because they
thought he could become a world champion
no no no they did it because they knew
it would bring eyeballs
well you can bring more eyeballs than CM
Punk is Dylan danis and he also is a
world class jiu-ju practitioner he's
also undefeated in mixed martial arts he
also fought in Bellator twice and he's
two and
0 so the argument there uh if you want
to say yo look look at what he did in a
box match against Logan Paul that
actually has nothing to do with it as
far as credential mixed martial artist
Dylan danis is more qualified than a lot
of guys UFC brings on board to sell
tickets so it's not far-fetched for the
UFC to at least entertain it
yeah I could see him doing it I I would
like to see him in it in the UFC oh if
I'm the UFC I do it you put Dylan D on
one of those main cards but you if you
put him as the main event on Fight Night
it's gonna be your most watched event of
the
year you put him as a co-main event or
even as the first fight on a main card
on a pay-per-view probably your most
watched pay-per-view that's just where
he's at
yeah I also remember seeing um something
about where this before Bellator you
know was going away like uh for Dylan to
even get that boxing match with Logan
Paul he had to pay a ton of money to
Scott Coker or Bellator because he's
still under contract I forgot about that
he was under releas they give a bunch of
money yeah just to do that
fight so back to Hamza apparently in
2021 remember when he I guess he got
coid and then he he got really sick he
said he was going to retire or something
like that and then I think Rogan said
like he's just training with Co so he's
just got made it worse and worse he just
revealed recently uh on the nek boys
podcast that his one of the doctors he
went to cuz he was coughing up blood he
said that he actually had cancer so he
thought he had cancer he had to go to
another doctor to get uh you know the
other diagnosis but is it one of those
doctors in the Middle East must be dude
so that's why he retired or kind of got
close to reti but then yeah he got the
second diagnosis and he was not he
didn't have cancer but that's crazy
cancer Miss diagnosis led to brief 2021
retirement it's in your head yeah he
just said it was in his
like uh that time was hard man it's not
the same man you know that one time I
said the doctor said to me coming down
that you have cancer that's why I said I
was retired I didn't know what to say to
my family I didn't know what to say to
people then we check again the other
doctor said no you don't have cancer
dumbass but I'm threw that in there but
that's what I if I was the doctor you
don't have cancer dumb ass uh but I'm
still coughing up blood still once if a
doctor said something to you it's in
your head you still go home you're
coughing up blood and
it's uh crap uh like that is unfinished
man yeah if someone tells you have
cancer like especially credential doctor
dude that would be freaking
devastating yeah couldn't
imagine but thankfully he doesn't yeah
thank god um here are some bout
announcements Cody garbrandt your boy
versus priman killer your boy yeah I
know yeah 296 love that fight somebody
getting put to sleep
I'm not picking on that one I like both
those guys
yeah and also on that same card it's not
there J jakad versus Jos that's a good
one I mean the lineup is pretty damn
dope oh this card
is tasty dude that main event you have
uh Edwards was Kobe comington taking my
money you have pentasia uh Brandon Royal
you have shots Wonderboy Tony Fon Patty
piml viente luk Ian Machado Gary they
have giga Josh EMT jacobe menafield Cody
garbrandt Brian
Keller great fights it's a great card
yeah hell yeah take my
money um so this is this is just a funny
one so that during the embedded episode
uh kamaro Usman was wearing one of
Francis ando's like Shir they blur it
out that's just so lame right just so
paty that is the the pettest so petty
after you know Francis you know he was
your champ man can't you blur out it's
Ro a fight Ro a fight's been associated
with UFC for a hot second they've made a
ton of merch for the biggest Legends in
the game you you got to blur out the
shirt for God's
sakes yeah but he took it in TR like
he's made fun of it kind of right here
but that fight's Saturday right yes the
28th Tyson Fury that's the Saturday the
Saturday and it's like early in the day
I think yeah cu the Middle East holy
shnikies
but yeah uh another quick little
break oh man let's take another little
break cuz you guys know me I only
recommend products that I actually use
like
Shopify like uh black Buffalo rain
energy whatever it is your boy actually
uses it I reach out to these guys to be
part of the show because I swear by them
if you see me do any shows standup
podcast I'm in the gym your boys on that
happy hippo happy hippo helps you get
stuff done katum game can be the wild
west but I only trust happy hippo
however you want your creatum whether
it's gummies Taffy powders pills they
got K dips it's kind of like in the
pouch form they got the energy shots
they got the highly concentrated energy
shots they have the regular highly
concentrated without the energy it's the
only Crum that I trust it's happy hippo
go to happy hippo.com promo code is
thick 23 that's thic CC 23 for 20% off
for life for the best brain booster on
the planet all right we talking about
that crom from Happy Hippo it's happy
hippo.com promo code thick
23 all righty damn I can't believe
Francis Fury is this Saturday yeah and
speaking of Francis of Fury I thought
this was pretty interesting they made
this uh this display in London but so
this is uh Tyson Fury they didn't like
make his body even you know just a
little bit Slimmer they made it look
just like his body Oh you mean they made
it look like him what do you want him to
do I all you want do like all you want
to do like they did back in the day
during the they used to always make a
little bit a little bit more leaner
little old school gladi a where they're
just shred Ville no dude that's his b
that's him to at that's actually the
best statue I've ever seen I know it's
really good it's really good it's so
exact CU you know even back in the days
like the king Tutt days like all that
they used to be super out of shape they
made him
jacked yeah and even back with the with
the old school you know we're talking
about back in you know the ancient Rome
times you know they get they made him
jacked with little wieners apparently
having a big wiener was frowned upon
guess I'm not cool back in the day am I
right make fun of me
fellas I'm sorry I got a tail you know
just just the Laughing joke of the
Town whatever they made Francis come
this is the the best statue they made
Francis Francis they made Tyson Tyson
you can't have a jack tyon they did a
phenomenal job that's so dope if I'm
Francis I'm like can I have that when
you're because you're not going to leave
that up there no and they're big too
hell yeah but can I put that in my house
I don't want the giant Crown that's
weird I guess you could put in the back
make a hot tub out of
it yeah they gave they gave Fury love
handles just you know the titties yeah
that's whoever did that deserves a
goddamn promotion that is the best
statue spot I've ever seen uh all right
so this is a little inaccurate but um so
actually so the post is from combat talk
it says Fighters with the names ending
in o or E Eevee went 7even and0 and then
uh but you know anle didn't win it was
just a no contest but yeah they went
seven and0 no the best base is not
having a
mustache yeah only only one guy here has
a mustache but everyone else looks
exactly the best base having a beard a
beard yeah Kimbo had a beard D Stains
have a
beard
yeah it's also OB these guys don't get
twisted too every single guy you see on
there all these fights were in the
Middle East they're all huge favorites
for a reason so it's not like oh just
check it out man these guys had a great
night they were supposed to have a great
night it's not now if they were all
underdogs and they all had beards they
like damn there's something to it oh the
all the favorites won crazy in their own
backyard weird Oh you mean the guy from
Chia and the guy from dagistan won
because they fought two guys on
a 10day notice that aren't in their
weight class crazy I'm gonna grow my
beard
out dumb asses dumb asses what's this
chin uh so that's it here are the the
fights it's basically just a card for
Tyson Fury ooh bunch of thick boys you
have 1 2 three 4 five six seven
heavyweight fights and then a light
middleweight kick rocks light
middleweight we're just big boys this is
First Team all thick that is October
28th that's this freaking Saturday it
goes down start time 1 pm Eastern so
that will be 11 what's that is that
10:00 a.m. here yeah it's 10 a.m. here
if that's if one Eastern uh but if you
really the fights don't really start
popping to Joseph Parker who we love
Joseph Parker first guest ever on a food
truck and I tried to get him to eat fish
in
Vegas and then you got sick or something
right uh was worried about getting sick
he was he was down to eat the eyeballs I
was not he was down to eat it and then
his coach went let's probably not do
this before the biggest fight of his
life I like you know what you're
probably right on this because we got
this fish in Vegas which is landlocked
and it was a raw fish for him uh but
Joseph Parker's fighting that's my
brother from a New Zealand mother
but obviously the main event you have
freaking Tyson Fury Francis and ganu um
if you're one of those people that are
like Tyson Fury is just going to
outclass him this is stupid I'm not
going to pay for this I get all that I
get all that but the one thing that
makes this different than a Connor vers
Floyd Logan Paul vers Floyd is Francis
and ganu if Tyson Fury for whatever
reason decides to take his eye off the
prize if he takes one
Nan off in that fight and Francis
happens to land a left hook an uppercut
a right hand whatever it is that fight
is over that's why you're paying for
this fight is he gonna outbox Tyson Fury
and not in a CH not a chance but is
there a possibility at a plus 700 he can
land an uppercut a left hook a right
hand in a frenzy there's a chance and I
want to be part of that I'm going be
watching it Francis is that damn
talented he can hit if I'm his coach I'm
going caution the win we're not training
any technique you're GNA freaking Homer
simp this thing run at him like you did
against Rosen stro do that we're not can
to try and be cute and sit back and pick
this dude forget your jab forget what
you have what we're doing on the pads
this is a street fight if you sit back
and you try to outbox Tyson Fury he's
going to change your life and it's not
going to be good if you if this thing
goes the distance you will never fight
the same ever again he's going to box
your brains in we don't want that go out
on your Shield you in order to win Franc
has to get this done with pure chaos in
two rounds if this thing goes past two
rounds it's G to get dicey and it's
going to get ugly Tyson Fury is the best
heavyweight to ever put on those 10 o
gloves I'll take all your debates who
you want a Vander bring it Tyson bring
it who else you got bring
it Lennox
Lewis George Foreman whatever he's the
best to ever do it he can do he can go
forwards he can go backwards he can po
shot he can out Clash he can do it all
we've never had anybody like that
Francis and gano's team knows this he
has throw caution the win make it
straight
up after school fight that's what he has
to do doesn't he get dirty none of those
Antics n the grappling you're not a
Grappler anyway no no no you just got to
land one shot and you got to do in the
first two rounds otherwise your life is
going to change
forever that's scary that's how hard he
hits though that's how hard Francis hits
and I'll I'll I'll take I'll take that
I'll take that all right is that it
almost um real quick though would you if
you were Francis would you go out
literally right away or just kind of
feel out first and then go
crazy I'm
literally ding
D how much did I
make now but if one of those lands we're
going so Sizzler we're changing the game
for it's the biggest upset in sports
combat history you're going so Sizzler
and you get the rematch no matter
what the only guy that loses If he if uh
Fury gets knocked out is a man named
usk because then you're you you got to
fight him and he just got knocked out
and it's GNA be a disaster that fight
goes to the garbage dude if Francis wins
biggest upset Combat Sports history a
guy who's never boxed professionally
knocks out the perennial best undefeated
Undisputed heavyweight champion of the
world what and he has the power to do it
take my money I am no in no shape or
form working with I don't know who's
even putting the fight on that should
tell you the
fight all righty well it's $79.99
according to this article okay maybe not
ESPN plus yeah 79.99 God I know that's
so expensive dude U couple fan questions
you
cool I think we're
good I think we're good all
right all right kids uh I'm in senica
that's right I'm Bas basically Buffalo
nigar Falls two shows almost sold out
one show Friday that's at senica casino
and Niagara Falls New York right outside
buffalo buffalo show some freaking
respect I played three minutes for your
team uh Buffalo New York that's Niagara
Falls New York November 3rd and 4th one
show Friday one show Saturday those bad
boys are almost sold out get tickets
right now them Chicago December 8th
through the 9th that's two shows Friday
two shows Saturday then just announced I
think I announced on Rogan show
Nashville I'm at zany's one night only
January 2 5th that's one show right now
only we will add shows if we have to but
that's Nashville Tennessee January 25th
that will sell out if we want to add
shows you better get on there now that's
Nashville Tennessee zany that's January
25th then I'm in
right right after January 26th and
January 27th Friday Saturday I'm in
Austin Texas that is January 26th and
27th get tickets right now at thick
boy.com but uh Buffalo New York Niagara
Falls Europe up first November 3rd
fourth then Chicago Nashville Austin get
you some uh for the the car content my
TRX is almost done we'll be launching
Toontown for you guys it's a car show
I'm modding crazy vehicles I'm going to
mod your vehicles my friends Vehicles
celebrities Comics athletes it's going
to be dope we're going be doing some
crazy stuff on there uh my car is going
from 702 horsepower right now about 1100
at the crank but we're adding on to that
um and I have one thing to do with Kibby
Tech on Wednesday and then the episode
the first episode will be out but stay
tuned for that I'll be making some
announcements on that front but uh it's
going to be fun all right guys all right
kids love you nagra fall see you
November 3rd and 4th uh be nice to each
other have fun I'm
out